i look completely different oh yeah i
just wanted to point that out i know we
like brushed over that but uh yeah
friendship with joey the anime man has
ended i'm josh the manga lad now yeah
you look like the hacker character in
the movie that doesn't want to explain
how hacking works
[Music]
am i going like crazy or is like the
internet gotten like the worst in like
the past five years am i crazy i don't
think you're crazy at all i feel like
it's gotten significantly worse
no no no the whole internet but the way
as in like the level of like [ __ ] up
[ __ ] yeah maybe maybe that was messed uh
there was a lot of messed up stuff like
you know five six years ago whatever but
like i feel like now it's all just out
there i feel like it's just so it's so
interesting how it's like almost like an
opposite effect that's happening like
for somehow for some reason
even though the internet or the internet
culture and people on the internet in
the past five six years have gotten more
pc than ever before
and yet
like almost counter-intuitively there's
more [ __ ] up [ __ ] that has like come
out onto the surface as well i think
that's why like retaliation maybe i
don't know
yeah you see the more that these people
because like like i've seen i see [ __ ]
now on like regular twitter and
instagram that you know you'd only have
a final like the [ __ ] b board yeah
it's weird man because you're just like
i'm
am i weird for for being like middle
ground on everything like i feel like i
have very normal opinions okay yeah but
the more i'm online i'm like am i am i
not normal do i have not normal opinions
yeah like what is a normal opinion yeah
yeah just like
just being i feel like being fair yeah
i'm like i don't really have heavy
opinions on well i see other people i'm
like oh my god yeah yeah i mean common
sense has definitely become less common
that's for sure no it's weird
i don't know what's common sense anymore
yeah it's
it does feel like is is this the point
where you know the
where the older generation starts
talking about [ __ ] talking the new
generation you know what i mean like
these damn kids yeah because
did you ever think like this is i i
think it's the opposite i i think it's
because the internet in general has
become more accessible to every age
group they were seeing all of this
because before it was just it was just
like 20 year olds who who gave enough
[ __ ] to go on yeah
yeah and i felt that it was a very
exciting time and everyone was like
really into it and you know and the new
website's probably the new hip thing
yeah mini clip was still thriving you
know farmville was still going strong um
mafia city i'm just going to keep naming
it we're good old days
i feel like now because it's become so
normalized and everyone uses it
like do you remember do you remember a
point where it felt like there was a
separation between what you did on the
internet and what happened in real life
oh absolutely and i feel like when that
barrier kind of like kind of like got
broken where you felt like what happened
in the internet was like was pertaining
to like your active your your at your
how can i say this
because like internet is real life but
it didn't feel so like
suffocating yeah you know it didn't feel
like you didn't feel like you had a yeah
had a tangible effect on your you know
on your day-to-day life but now it feels
like whatever's going on in the internet
whatever's going on in the world has
this tangible effect this tangible
uh
the tangible effect on what's going on
in you know what you're doing you
literally just explain the plot to
serial experiments lane
like that's oh yeah i kind of literally
what that is so what's what's the time
you think it is i'm curious if you have
the same opinion on this what'd you what
you said the time when it felt like that
became
the time when it felt like i became like
i feel it depends on how long you've
been on the internet right like yeah did
you ever do like myspace
uh no i came right after mike did you do
much did you have did you bebo
i had b-boys i did that was very popular
in the yeah okay yeah would you would
you say like so like the bebo and
myspace here right it's like roughly the
same time i would say yeah right like
when you were on bibo and when people on
myspace were on myspace did you see that
as like this is
me like completely tangible
social media is a game right yeah it's
it's like how i go into sims and i make
myself look attractive i think yeah
because like that's how i kind of traded
myspace at the time right it's just it's
just yeah it's like it's like a social
zone right yeah yeah yeah it's it's like
i i think i think what really uh the the
first time i really thought of social
media as
a game was actually uh
so charlie brooker do you know charlie
brooker he wrote black mirror yeah so
like a few years ago or maybe even a
decade ago i can't remember how old this
video is he did like a top 50 most
influential games of like all time
and uh like number one was twitter like
that like and and i was just like what
are you talking about charlie brooker
because before that he talked about you
know games like that's not a game last
of us [ __ ] tetris you know all these
games and now and he was just like well
think about it you play as an avatar on
an online platform where you gain points
for interacting with the game and i'm
just like
yeah i mean he's kind he's very right
he's like social media at this point is
a game and we are all for like
the game now is our job you know it it
it is our job because we're falling
right into the system we are we are part
of the system guys
we can't criticize the system because we
are the system we are the system we are
part of the system but that that is
definitely how
social media has become and i mean like
in a way like i see especially like
youtube and stuff as like a kind of like
a game i mean it's been it's been
gamified to [ __ ] you post the video
you post a video and it even puts you on
a leaderboard on like how well it's
performed in like the thought in the
past 10 vid uploads you've done but but
the game
the the stakes to it or whatever you
give it yeah like a game is it's the
same with anything right like it you
know [ __ ] jump king whatever whatever
it is it's the game zero days the game
only means whatever you you assign to it
yeah right so if you with the videos
right if you're making these videos for
the purpose of of cracking that one out
of ten then yeah if you're making the
video because you want to make a video
and i think when i win yeah like when
you get to that point it's like you're
kind of testing the limits on what you
can call a game right like you know is
the stock market a game
repercussions
it's rule out where there's a really
really boring option that will probably
pay you back or you can spin the wheel
yeah spin the wheels
[Laughter]
it's like deal or no deal but it's
actually serious yeah i felt like the i
don't know when the internet started to
become very very real if you will yeah
uh but it definitely jacked up to 100 at
2016. i think that was when it
definitely like
2016.
election huh first presidential uh
trump's
i feel like that's when it just went
boom
that's when like the two the split went
like crazy i felt like the the
left-leaning internet right-wing
internet just went
really full-on i feel like i think
i think it might be earlier and it's
just that we weren't really aware of it
yeah you know you know you know what it
was i'm saying i've started then but
that's when that's when the dial went
like [ __ ] 500. yeah you know when it
was right that's when youtube rewind
started becoming [ __ ]
when everything on the internet stopped
being universally loved yeah yeah yeah
basically when we started like being
segmented i guess i i just like i'm just
going i just tried to verbalize how i
felt and i'm just like kind of feels
around the same time that i stopped
giving a [ __ ] about youtube rewind yeah
so that kind of feels like it was 2014
2013 maybe
very like very early on when i stopped
when the when the internet stopped being
like one conglomeration and just beca
and you'd see things happening and you
just didn't recognize who this person
was who that person was people stopped
getting along uh and you know factions
and groups started to form and uh yeah
but that's why i took something like the
presidential election which is like the
most
uh televised
horse race in existence yeah you will
it's like it's so you know other
countries we don't you know the uk it's
like yeah we have this whole thing about
who the new prime minister is going to
be but yeah we don't nearly like make it
as exciting you know as america does
america's so good at me i mean
so i felt like it was the perfect event
that was so polarizing and so well
telegraphed with so much information and
so many parties putting stuff into it i
think regardless of your opinion on it
yeah and who you who you voted for i
don't give a [ __ ] i'm just saying you
can't ignore the fact that this was a
thing that just really took the internet
and just [ __ ] right i think it's also
around the time roughly when like a lot
of social media sites were like just
where that kind of discussion was just
becoming more open like that was roughly
around the time where like twitter
increased their like character limit
yeah people were like so people you know
could only tweet about like yay obama
one and that was it and now it was like
let me write a full [ __ ] novel about
how i feel about this presidential
election and then you know this is when
they also
after that is when the platform started
having to
correct misinformation yeah and that
further caused more of a device yeah and
then now there's just definitely
different platforms for different
opposing views so now you don't even get
you don't even get to hear the other
side yeah
yeah i feel like what was so prevalent
about just not just the presidential
election but just that year in general
was that it felt like that was the real
turning point for
where social media kind of felt just
like a tv show it was like a part of
entertainment right where the the the
presidential uh election is the most is
the best rated tv show of all time i'd
probably say yeah everybody tunes in to
watch the next episode yeah i mean like
i mean it even had like a build up
season uh which was uh brexit right yeah
yeah
we had like the mid-season was that the
pilot
that was the mid-season twist right we
had the mid-season twister we're like
guys
this show can't get any better there's
no possible way they can surprise me
jokes on you you'll never expect what
comes next
just just [ __ ] look right look at the
how they decide the nominee for the
presidential thing look at that [ __ ]
it's it's laid out like who wants to be
a millionaire
they're in the semi circle with all this
amazing [ __ ] tv show s britain's got
talent background and they all take
turns a massive audience and [ __ ] what
is this [ __ ] like what
who gives a [ __ ] let the party pick and
then we'll [ __ ] decide who wins
this whole thing is so
reality tv show-esque yeah it's so
bizarre like when you sit down and
you're like what am i watching like this
is this is [ __ ] up yeah like okay
here's a question do you think that
people cared about politics as much
before and we were just like too
ignorant because we were like too young
at the time
or do you think people care more now
because of the prevalence of social
media and just so many people
verbalizing their opinions and
i don't think it has to do with the
amount of people caring i think this
just has to do with how much
we are just exposed to it now
yeah so i i think one of the main things
here is that you have to bear in mind as
well that i think like with
with the internet this is just giving
everyone the platform yeah yeah so like
before if you wanted to if you wanted to
get support as a politician you had to
go on like a tv show and then say
something right yeah you only had like
what or if you're in japan you blare out
of a [ __ ] megaphone in the stream
annoyingly so like now it's like okay so
you have like the kind of perfect storm
of like
now there's more ways to to discuss
everyone's on the internet not even 40
50 year olds are on the internet so
they're willing to listen to you yeah
combine that with the fact that it's
become really easy to give
politics a kind of tribalism with
nothing to do with it right so the whole
vaccination thing or whatever and all
that nonsense
non-vaccines nonsense about the whole
argument around it yeah yeah it very
quickly stopped becoming about the
science and more just about like which
horse are you backing yeah right so i
feel like now it became political it's
gotten really easy to just assign
identities to certain political views
yeah and this is how politicians have
realized that they can push their agenda
it's by just giving it like are you a
real american then you believe in this
right it's like how about you if you
push it used to be before i felt like it
was just about more so it was like this
is the policy this is what we're gonna
do and now it's like all right we have
to give everything a meaning are you
you're either with us or you're not
here's the meaning between it and all
that kind of [ __ ] i could explain this
better if i was more eloquent with my
words but unfortunately that isn't the
case i mean i mean they did that subtly
with the whole ebola crisis right that
was the exact same thing like it
suddenly became like a are you with us
or are you not with us do you care about
these people then you should be with me
it's like but it's got nothing to do
with it in what case sorry the ebola
stuff like what what what do you mean
well like it very quickly became like
especially in america it became like a
political drive right for like the
campaigns and whatnot and it's just like
well oh was it yeah i don't remember
yeah it absolutely did and then when the
actual election finished
everyone stopped talking about it
because it's as if it had nothing to do
with the american elections yeah because
i think it's just it's much easier
instead of proving yourself right to
prove the other person wrong oh yeah by
proving the other person wrong you're in
a sense proving yourself right even
though that's not how it works at all
you know like when did uh
when did like ben shapiro start owning
people with facts and logics right
because i feel like that's when it
started you know around the same time i
believe yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
probably when it was when it wasn't
about
being involved in politics it was just
like you know you start off watching
someone else just like owning other
people when they're like logistical like
logical arguments whatever you know it
became part of entertainment
what's this guy the proved me wrong guy
oh um steven crowder steven crowder yeah
i like that as well just like [ __ ]
exploded out of nowhere too yeah it's
weird how seeing the seeing these waves
come up first it's just like you know
you you have the group that proves the
other group wrong and then and then
after a while people get bored of that
and then it's like people proving that
group wrong and it's just it's just like
it's it's a constant you know it's it's
a constant ping-pong [ __ ]
yeah
you know there's it's information on a
lot of things there's always way more
nuance than people want to to get into
right so a lot of the time if you just
take one correct argument or one correct
fact about a flawed argument right you
can just run with that and push that and
say like look this is this is right even
though in in context it might be
incorrect but you can just keep running
with something that that you know that
you you can parrot and it's safe to do
so yeah and even then even if you're
wrong it doesn't matter because as we've
learned is that if you're a narcissist
and you're willing to not give a [ __ ]
people are trying to cancel you yeah
people have real people have learned
that canceling only does [ __ ] if if you
give a [ __ ] yeah and and
people are being rewarded in mass
you know and a lot of those people like
that who uh
even though they get [ __ ] wrong as long
as they don't give a [ __ ] and they just
make something new or don't mention it
and just continue on it doesn't matter
you get what you want you get your
platform you continue you can get new
followers oh you lost you lost a few
hundred followers oh you'll get a new
thousand who cares yeah yeah exactly
it's like negative it's there's never
been more of a time when
i've realized that you know bad was it
like bad press or bad like there was no
such thing as bad bad press press yeah
because
it's as bad as you you give a [ __ ] and
yeah the thing is as well as a lot of
people have realized and a lot of uh you
see this on youtube's own influences
it's as bad as you let it seem it is as
well so if you're like you know that's
that's why a lot of the scandals around
the presidential election that happened
in 2016
a lot of them
because
if the guy who you're supporting is like
it's not a big deal yeah then maybe
you'll be like oh it's not a big deal
yeah i guess not yeah yeah yeah you know
like there's kind of there is a kind of
uh it's as bad as they let it seem right
yeah if you address it be like i don't
give a [ __ ] or you don't even bother to
address it then you know
yeah i mean yeah i mean i think
i think you're right in a sense and i i
feel like even more so was when it was
like when trump got elected like you
know regardless of your opinion you know
of him as the president
for me as an outsider who is you know
not any part of american politics it was
almost like watching a character in a
show you know it's like like like see
like going on your twitter timeline and
seeing some of the stuff that he's like
cartoon villain yeah yeah yeah like
remember like the whole cod fifth [ __ ]
that shows like i don't care what where
you lie in the political spectrum i
think we can all unanimously agree that
call fifth was [ __ ] hilarious
and yeah it kind of like i don't know
what the right word is but it kind of
like cartoonified [ __ ] yeah it kind of
like cartoonified your you know your
real life and you know the world events
even though
even though there is you know even
though these were real prevalent issues
and yeah he's had a real
car
these had these had a real tangible
effect on the world and i feel like
especially a lot of the younger
generation who you know who have grown
up in the age of the internet um that's
that's kind of like the environment
they've grown into you know where where
everything when it's seen through a
phone or through you know through uh
with through a tablet they just like
it's like suddenly not real yeah because
we're like we were like what 20 plus
when all this start happened i know yeah
20 uh yeah maybe just nine i was like
19. like i've i couldn't imagine going
from like 12 to like 18. yeah and this
has been your like entire
memory yeah yeah yeah weird yeah yeah
it's really bizarre yeah crazy and you
know we don't talk about it on the
podcast or political views or our
political opinions because
the most part i don't give a [ __ ] what
you believe in
yeah yeah
i have my own opinions but i'm also not
i'm not like
i don't think i'm some kind of
benevolent man who knows
i know that i have come to conclusions
on things with through flawed
like uh thinking methodology whatever
the [ __ ] you say just because of how
i've been raised right and you've been
raised whatever way you have and if you
disagree with me on things i don't give
a [ __ ] how you came about pollution i'm
not gonna judge you i feel like one of
the biggest problems that's come out of
all this is that everyone's calling each
other stupid for believing in something
yeah and i'm like i'm sure you have a
reason if if we if we just spoke to each
other normally and didn't polarize each
other all the [ __ ] time yeah
just you know agree to disagree right
it's like we're not here to [ __ ] like
you know dangle a [ __ ] carrot in
front of your face being like believe us
because we we we hold the truth and it's
like no no one does it sucks as well
because obviously with the whole crown
of our stuff and that all got
politicized of course of course it did
that unfortunately came at the cost of
people's lives yeah and you know the
people who felt they were right felt so
strongly they were right because they
thought that you know they're like yeah
we have to protect people and yeah
that's fair enough but it's it's kind of
difficult to convince people when you're
calling them stupid yes it's been shown
that it doesn't work no no no i mean i
think another big massive thing with the
age of the internet is just like the
[ __ ] overload of information yeah
right where where it's like i remember a
point where you you know read something
in a book or read a newspaper or
something and you know you'd you'd kind
of like educate yourself but it feels
like there is just so much information
right now that i don't even know what
information is the right information to
educate myself right so a lot of the
time so many times i look at something
online and i think like oh man this is
kind of interesting piece of information
a couple of hours later i found out it's
total [ __ ]
welcome it's like what the [ __ ]
welcome to real life yeah literally
every time i'm just like
where sometimes you even you hear about
a story or an event and you're like [ __ ]
man that [ __ ] sucks
yeah i get told by like five or six
different people being like have you
seen this thing and i'm like well [ __ ]
if there's five or six people around me
that i know yeah and i understand yeah
who's telling me that this is happening
then it must be true and i'm like turns
out no all [ __ ] when you were a kid
right did you think that people were
stupid
like you think that you're like too
smart in what context just in general
like as a kid i was one of those little
kids that just thought like in school i
think half the reason why i was angry
half the time right because i thought
like this is so dumb i'm smarter than
all this
right i can't even remember i just want
to play video games i didn't really
i didn't feel that strongly about things
and so i i i was like i thought as a kid
i just thought i was smarter than people
around me right yeah right i think
everyone had that phase though right
right but i think people don't grow out
some people don't grow up some people
don't grow out of it obviously yeah
because it's really interesting because
i was just scrolling on reddit yeah god
forbid and i i saw this and it was like
a post where i was like i think everyone
else is dumb and it's infuriating having
to talk to people right yeah and then it
was really interesting seeing how people
were trying to reply to this and kind of
like break it down and ultimately and i
i think this is really good and i think
that everyone should keep this in mind
because i feel that
we judge people based on how they speak
not how their level of intelligence is
yeah right and i feel like this
definitely happens on the podcast i've
seen it in the comments section where we
might have a bad take or we might badly
explain something and everyone's like
well connor's dumb or joey's down god's
damn he couldn't explain this like
it's it's so hard to grasp
we only can interact with people based
on the things they say right not how
they think because you're probably
thinking about things way deeper than
you could ever explain oh yeah about it
right and it's so hard to
get that out of your head when someone's
talking to you because you have to you
only have that to work i mean it's a
skill and that's why like i have trouble
properly expressing myself unless it's
written down yeah which is why i
screamed right right which we can't do
on the podcast you can't join the
podcast unfortunately but like uh we
can't like edit it either so like that's
why like i i know for a fact that i
express myself best in like text form or
like written form but but also i think
you're you you're quite eloquent with
the way you worked things and i think i
think so i mean i've had some pretty
[ __ ] things
there has been several points where i
look at myself arguing an argument and
i'm just like i'm a [ __ ] clown why
why i deserve to be [ __ ] true
it's been like it's a normal thing where
they'll be like i get what connor is
saying but he explained it badly yeah
yeah
and i will admit i'm extremely guilty of
that i i do that a lot and there are a
lot of things that i try to explain but
in the moment it's just hard to get the
worst because we don't come into this
it's not a debate we don't script this
[ __ ] we just turn it off you know it's
like i can't i get what you mean but you
probably should have double checked this
like the whole uh the [ __ ] the food
illness thing it's like yeah if you gave
me 20 minutes in a room alone
this is how real life is and it's weird
because i feel like when i watch people
as well speak and again this is this is
going back to how just general life
again this this ties into the previous
topics with the online right how how we
respond to people who have or might be
uh have bad opinions on things
we observe to be bad opinions it's like
it's so hard
in this current climate online to just
give people the benefit of the doubt
yeah be like i think you mean well and i
don't think like this this opinion you
have that could be hurting people i
don't think you genuinely want to hurt
people yeah it could be like you just
have a bat you just you have been
misinformed and you believe yeah yeah
you genuinely think this is helping
people that's that's the problem though
is that like i feel you know a lot of
social media like twitter reddit stuff
like that is like 99 emotionally driven
yeah right because of just humanity yeah
but also you know a lot a lot of people
like to think that like oh i see this
massive post on you know massive comment
replying to a certain [ __ ] take on
reddit right and they think like oh
judging from the length of this whole
thing this must be a very well thought
well written argument 90 percent of the
time no it's emotionally just it's
emotional drivel but that's
unfortunately how the nature of a lot of
these internet arguments work right it's
so depressing you just like even when
you go on the reddit i'm like look at it
and it's just someone will say something
that's a bit incorrect and it'll just
immediately turn into like
argument yeah yeah yeah it's like i was
like
why why do you want to do this
it's like no one's [ __ ] citing their
sources in these kinds of comment
sections it's all it's all emotional
yeah i mean like that's i mean that's
just how humans are like always and yeah
that's why like that's why i don't
normally try to get involved on like a
platform like twitter because like i
do you think anyone's ever changed their
[ __ ] mind from like a single tweet or
like
or or like a twitter discussion i don't
i can't see it happening i'd love to
meet someone who's like you know i
thought about this thing but then i saw
you know uh xxx noob killer xx tweet
that i'll be like yeah you know what
you're right bro
opinion changed yeah just like that yeah
i've seen i've seen threads that maybe
you know well you know we'll just agree
to disagree you know the threads that
you you open up that like show all
replies and you just keep scrolling down
and it just never ends
i see people civilized on the internet
and always being really respectful each
other is when they're talking about porn
yeah that's the only time yes people do
people are so [ __ ] polite to each
other when they're talking about porn
and they're so helpful and everyone's so
helpful about it but the moment it's
anything else it's like it they just
start going at the throats it's the
image of like all the board members
yeah i just love as well the ones that
are like you know going back to the
whole like agreeing to disagree thing
like i've seen so many twitter replies
of like how one side of the the argument
tries to you know start that whole
conclusion not being like you know what
let's agree to disagree but ninety
percent of the time the other party's
like no no no no no yeah we're not
ending it here i'm not gonna agree to
disagree [ __ ] you how dare you you you
know this that people feel for some
reason feel safe discussing their
opinions about uh port and hen time
whatever because on some of these
discord servers where they talk about
hentai people use their real [ __ ]
pictures as their profile pictures
that's how safe they feel talk what the
[ __ ] that's the that's the real safe
space that is the real space safe space
man what it's like
it's bold it's like i mean
i'm into ntr let's agree to disagree
this episode is sponsored by honey the
easy way to save when shopping on your
iphone or computer guys let's not
pretend that we don't all shop online
right of course we do but you wish you
had a promo code ready for you always
when you're at the checkout or thanks to
honey manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past honey is a
free shopping too that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best one it finds to your cart every
time you shop online how does it work
connor imagine it you're shopping on one
of your favorite sites yeah when you're
at the checkout the honey button appears
and all you have to do is click apply
coupons that's all wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons it can find
for that site if honey finds a working
coupon you'll watch the prices drop it's
not easy it's that easy and recently i
just bought a microphone to upgrade my
setup and honey saved me 15 bucks what a
brand new microphone if you don't
already have honey you can be straight
up missing out on free savings am i
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and also supporting us as well
i never recommend something i don't use
so get honey for free at
joinhoney.comtaste that's jointhoney.com
slash trash taste links in the
description below that's the episode why
is it that like the porn community on
twitter is like some of the like
chillest people the porn community in
any community
the chillest people isn't it [ __ ] up
that like a pornhub comment section is
more chill than like a youtube comment
section
i feel like because you you to have to
interact in a community you have to have
a level of self-awareness i think oh
yeah yeah so i think that's where it
comes from it's like you're so
self-aware that you just don't give a
[ __ ] anymore and that's when you're most
zen yeah yeah well basically it's it's a
massive barrier of entry just to sign up
an account to a porn site right that's a
level that i just haven't been able to
take
i just don't want to give my my gmail
i just want to i just want to be at that
morning where i'm like i wake up in the
morning like making a pornography
this is the most trash taste segway ever
by the way can you say that that we've
gone from like very serious topics to
signing up to a pornography i don't know
what kind of person is like i need to
just have my say in this i gotta have my
i've got to make it known what i think i
feel like there's steps because i've
never signed up for a pornhub account
yeah i have for like hentai sites right
right i have yeah because i have yeah
because sometimes you find like a like a
lit hentai you're like i want to
remember this because i'm going to
forget the name i will say that put in
the book
as a free to play user of the the porn
universe i will say the the he's the
most annoying thing is trying to find a
video that i did enjoy yeah because
because the problem is you know after
you do the deed you just you're not
interested in it anymore so you're like
i don't [ __ ] need this anymore and
then you just like it just goes out the
recesses of your mind and like [ __ ] a
week later you're like yo what was that
[ __ ] like a class hentai that i found
there's a sobering moment when you're
trying to type in the keywords to find
the thing yeah and you're like i'm
disgusting
and you're just scrolling through these
videos trying to find it and you're like
no
no there's something wrong with me i've
gone to the point where i've like
anonymously gone into forums and asked
what's your profile pic i'm not telling
you
do you know what anonymously it's gotta
be cherry i want it to be yeah yeah no
one would ever expect the joey to use
his actual profile picture on the forum
that's true but now everyone's going to
use channels
[Applause]
yeah but it's like i was yeah because i
was like i didn't know anyone at the
time right and i was in the exact same
situation where i was like i just saw
this thing but it was on incognito
so i don't remember what it was called
all i remember is like what the girl oh
my god you could log in do you know the
login information do you still use this
account no not anymore i don't i don't
even think the website exists anymore
yeah that is the one problem with
incognito mode is that it it doesn't
give you a search history yeah or like
or like a history like the moment the
post night clarity hits and you close
that window you're like
why did i do that i can't i can't go
back now
oh my god so yeah i was like one time i
i remember it i was like i remember what
the girl looked like and i remember like
a certain scene so i was just like hey
i'm looking for this one series um these
are the details i help appreciate it
immediately like five people came back
being like i think it's this one you
should look it up none of them were
actually yet but i got great
recommendations we've got some new
recommendations along the way that's
pretty close oh
yeah normal one i don't know what would
compel me to want to pay
well like what do you mean like a peso i
wouldn't want to give my [ __ ] credit
card to one of these
dude that feels like such a you know
when you hear about these uh which one
was it was it the new york guy who was
running for mayor of new york
anthony weiner was it
something no there was somebody who got
remembered i think it was one with dick
pics yeah that was it there was someone
else who was like they were running for
a political position and then it was
found out they were spending like
like five grand a month on pornography
or something and i was like i was like
that's impressive that yes to find
ways to spend five grand that is
impressive you're definitely not
watching all of it that's for sure yeah
because how could you i don't think one
person is capable of watching that much
porn how many many uh how many like how
yeah how many only fans was these like
sub two
i don't remember who it was i do
remember yeah that sounds familiar it's
like the most chad youtuber apology not
apology video yeah yeah he was never
accused of anything he just came out
he's like guys i have a porn addiction
it's rough i was like yeah well it was
like literally ruining his life right
yeah well i it's one of those things
that i can always die i always [ __ ]
say it's one of those things god damn i
gotta stop saying that connor this is a
message to you stop saying it's one of
those questions
it's literally my question for you
i
it's one of those
[Laughter]
that people talk about and
oh sorry people do not talk about it now
yeah yeah and
it
it's one of those people don't want to
give credit to it or talk about it
because it's just really embarrassing oh
yeah of course don't give credit to how
debilitating it can be to have that
if you have it man i hope you can get
help i hope you can get out of it no
shame to you man i i i it's because it's
hard it's it's because it's something
that's just like it doesn't seem like on
the forefront of things you should be
worried about
like you know you can easily it's it's
easy to be able to justify to yourself
oh yeah a gambling addiction of course
that's bad you know you're like
your life or like an alcohol addiction
right i'm just kind of destroying my
body i'm destroying all my relationships
around me like a porn addiction because
like porn is so secretive anyway you
know you don't really have anyone to
talk to it about it's not it's not an
immediate threat i think it's the thing
because like you know you hear about
he's like yeah i of course i watch porn
i'm an adult it's everyone does it it's
fine you know everyone most people are
normal living normal lives you know
while watching everything and then you
know you go down the rabbit hole deep
enough and you realize oh it's actually
[ __ ] like like we're just as bad at
which point do you like accept that it
is an addiction and not just like a
recreational activity that everyone does
you know what i mean like i think i
think like i don't know it's like when
it when it games to addicting right yeah
yeah yeah yeah
is it is it the hours spent consuming
that medium or is it the money spent
yeah consuming that medium or is it both
i don't know is it when you can't think
of anything other than politics because
no no one wants to help people who are
addicted to porns i don't think it's
like a thing yeah because they're like
just just stop watching it
oh just something just
like to me like i guess i don't know
what the actual definition of addiction
is but i guess when you should start
being worried about it is when it has
like i guess like a
tangible
effect on maybe your life or in in some
way shape or form but like what is like
like affecting negatively yeah yeah
that's it like a tangible negative
effect in your life or an aspect of your
life but then again like when does it
become a negative effect when does it
because just become like oh yeah i just
had a week binge drinking with the boys
because we were like partying a week you
know like like at which point does it
become a negative effect i don't know i
guess that's the hard thing about it i
think it's when it's
i think in my opinion i think it's when
it's like it's consistently for a long
period of time and it's consistently
just adding on to a negative effect i
think that's when it becomes like a
problematic addiction because like you
can like as you said like you could have
like a week binge of like drinking from
morning till night with your boys right
yeah but you're most likely not gonna be
drinking for a while after that right
like that i wouldn't count that as an
addiction like that's like a short-term
like [ __ ] that's just destroying your
body yeah that's just that's just
destroying your body having a good time
with the boys right but like you know
when it's like a constant amount every
day or you know for a long period of
time consistently yeah and it's just
getting worse and worse and worse and
worse i think that's when it's like yeah
okay you should probably seek help kind
of thing that in my opinion i don't know
it's when you sign up to a pornhub
account it's when you you're like you
know what i need people to know how i
feel about that [ __ ] scene like that
it was so good i need upvotes on my
pornhub
that's the one thing i don't understand
i understand like i i the thing about
pornhub comments is that i understand
people asking about like say [ __ ]
call of duty's tactics or like [ __ ]
how to get past this level uh rather
than people actually yeah rather than
people actually commenting on the porn
itself like to me for some reason like i
don't know why you would ever comment
on like a porno right as like because
you're either like watching it and
you're actively involved or like i've
never gotten to a point where i'm
watching this i'm just like i want to
verbalize what i think what do people
think about this yeah what i what i
think about this you know my favorites
are the ones that are just like just so
simple like so so innocent being like oh
man 1823 what a hot scene i was like
yeah
i guess so like
thank you for sharing that um
i wish i was that open i wish i was yeah
yeah maybe one day every one
you want to get to that point who knows
who knows
who knows have you seen some of the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that sydney's been tweeting
you know like i need to [ __ ] calm her
down sometimes yeah yeah
does i wouldn't be surprised if she had
a porno account
at this point i think it's just twitter
she's gone beyond yeah she's gone beyond
man
like why be anonymous when i can be
known oh god jesus anyway have you guys
been up to anything this past week
that's not been depressing or uh i look
completely different oh yeah just wanted
to point that out like
i know we like brushed over that but uh
yeah it's uh the friendship with joey
the anime man has ended i'm josh the
manga lad now
just the comments just like so
i got my ears pierced yeah that's one
big thing and then just yesterday i got
my hair cut yes so now i look completely
different yeah you look like the
the hacker character in the movie that
doesn't want to explain how hacking
works
it just kind of like pisses everyone off
yeah but
they always need him yeah yeah the the
one that that guy yeah i look like that
guy now
but like i just loved uh
so you know because i had like the every
time like i feel this is very much like
a youtuber thing but like even if like
you slightly change how you look yeah or
you know slightly do something different
right it's like to some people it's like
what the [ __ ] it's like the end of the
world type of thing right yeah this is
youtube comments work on
the first thing they think they can
comment about they comment yeah so it's
always the appearance because you see
that yeah and it's like every time i get
like my hair cut or like i shave or you
know i guess in this case you know
drastically change quite a bit my
favorite things is just like seeing the
reception to it regardless of if it's
positive or negative like you know to
all the people who said like hey joe you
look good
i appreciate that that's [ __ ] dope
thank you but my favorites are the ones
that of people just like losing their
minds in a negative sense like like a
family member just yeah yeah it was the
funniest responsibility the funny stuff
so the one i saw on it's always
instagram that are the best ones okay
okay um but like when i when i got the
when i posted the pictures of my getting
my ears pierced the top comment for a
while was
is he gay or european
and i was like yes i am a jojo fan thank
you
but then you know with the haircut for
instance like you know some people are
like hey you know i like your cut g you
know you always get those and then other
ones were like you know just like i
can't believe it he is like l plus ratio
he fell off
you fell off
yeah i saw one i saw one i saw a quote
retweet that was dead are saying like
you [ __ ] fell off and i was like well
his hair definitely did
yeah yeah
it's like what because i got a haircut
it was the same when i moved to japan
the same video i also dyed my hair yeah
yeah and even though i'd moved to japan
half the comments were just like oh my
god his hair
was like i just moved to japan
yeah like like your hair was like it's
like oh i have different hairs you know
responsible for different funnies now
you
i just like the fact that you've had
like longer hair and like the same
length there now you have like shorter
hair uh to be fair this is the shortest
i think i've ever had it yeah it's it's
weird does it feel good it feels good
the background feels good yeah but it's
like easy to how easy it is is it to
wash now oh
that's the best part about having a
short hair it's it's it's amazing i love
it but like yeah i don't know it's like
so many people were like why would you
do that to yourself
like why would you do that it's like
like i [ __ ] stabbed a kid like it's
like it's like why would you why would
you do that now and i was like
why not
so as someone who like rarely ever
changes their hairstyle how do you guys
pick what hairstyle that you like that
you like do or like how did you how did
you pick a new hairstyle i'm not
confident enough in my own abilities to
ever change my own style somebody else
has to do it for me right right then i'm
like
and then i stick with it yeah like to to
me every every time i have changed my
hairstyle in my life it's been someone
else recommending me a hairstyle to
change it to and i'm just like i don't
know if i like this i don't know if i
like this and it takes me like a good
old a good like gear or something it's
like build up my cars to be like okay
maybe maybe i'll go for this person's
advice and i change it and i'm like well
okay well this is my new hairstyle now
how did you transition from sasuke here
to now
oh is that a suggestion yeah it was a
suggestion by my mates because they were
like mate uh you need to put stop
putting this much gel into your [ __ ]
hair
[ __ ] just comb it down and you're
like no no the sasuke hair makes me
everyone loves it everybody loves it
it's never going to change like this for
the rest of my life and i do it once i'm
like yeah this is [ __ ] stupid i don't
know what's up i don't know what i was
thinking i've decided my hairstyle based
on what requires no gel or wax i just
hate putting [ __ ] in my hair yeah i
always hated that so i just like
whatever i can do when i roll out of bed
is the one i'm going for so envious yeah
i i i need i need yeah i know he's not
like perfectionist yeah he's like he's
hand sculpting the perfect i mean but i
mean before today's episode like
majority of episodes is just my bed head
wait i don't do anything with it it's so
funny though people asking like what
shampoo and conditioner do you use i was
like uh head and shoulders
[ __ ] dove like it's nothing special
yeah i don't know it's like for me it's
like
like i'm given like this you know job
right like
like youtubing and just like being on
social media where it's like
this isn't gonna [ __ ] affect like you
know my videos right like it doesn't
affect my job yeah it's just a matter of
like personal preference so in my head
it's like why if i'm given this
opportunity where
i can kind of experiment with how i look
and then not really affect my job you
know maybe it might even affect it
positively for some people why wouldn't
i try it it's like you know because like
with my hair for instance it's like if
you hate this hair just wait a month
it'll go back to normal
it's going to go back to the length
you're comfortable with it's fine but
it's like you know why would i not give
it a good but also i feel like a lot of
that is just people not being used to a
look or new yeah of course because i i
remember like like i remember when i
first started growing out like a stubble
and everyone's like oh you're like weird
as [ __ ]
and even i did i thought man i look
[ __ ] weird i look [ __ ] weird as
[ __ ] with just a stubble because i've
never had a stubble or i've never like
grown out a stubble in my life even
though i've always known i could and i
remember like i was like working on
my latest vlog and i was looking at you
know i was looking at my uh
my trash taste video when i talk about
trash taste and then uh i was looking at
the previous vlog i did before i was
recording this one and it was the bbc
video that i did without a stubble and i
was like
man i look [ __ ] weird like
like
now i think i look weird without a
stubble and i look back at all trash
taste episodes and i'm like man i look
really weird i don't know dude like when
you like go back to like episode one of
trash days and i'm in a [ __ ] ponytail
oh my god i completely
i look at that and i'm like you look
homeless
i'm so glad
i don't look like this anymore but back
then everyone was like yeah the jesus
hair dude it looks [ __ ] sick and back
then i was like yeah
yeah you know what it kind of looks sick
not gonna lie
but now i'm just like no it like it it
really got to the point where like i
knew it was gross when like even aki's
mom who was like the most like [ __ ]
accepting like kind like never says a
bad thing about anything just one day
was like i think you should cut your
hair
i was like if you're saying that
maybe i should yeah
i think maybe i should
i feel like i needed to hear that though
because like that's probably how dire i
looked
because like now now i know what she
means i look back and then i'm like yeah
you know what if i if i saw a guy like
that who i cared about i'd probably tell
him to cut his hair too yeah because
it's kind of gross but it's like yeah i
don't know it's like
even with the piercings as well it's
like it was surprising how a lot of
people are like oh i thought your ears
were already pissed yeah and i was like
yeah now that you say it i don't know
why
i know it's never been that way but like
you have you had like that energy where
you had your ears pierced and yeah you
did you did yeah really because like
when you said you got your ears pissed i
was like didn't you already have your
ears pierced or am i just like dreaming
that up yeah everyone said that and i
was like really it is weird how much
like just changing a little bit of your
facial features can change the
perception yeah when i was growing up my
beard a little bit i look like [ __ ]
willem dafoe from the lighthouse
and i was like i kind of digged it
though but also at the same time it was
really [ __ ] annoying yeah yeah yeah
having it long actually you actually
reminded me of linus tech tips more than
anything really yeah
i don't know why just like we don't
wanna wear sandals and socks side by
side of linus
i think he looks good with the beard
i just like it wasn't william to face it
was like it was like linus tech tips
with a beard energy that i got from me i
don't know i i take
is that like the biggest change you've
ever done aside from like getting your
hair dyed and everything like that
i think i think you turning silver was
the biggest change right that was weird
yeah well i look at that level weird i
liked it when it was half blonde half
brown kind of yeah dirty blonde like
when the silver was fading right yeah i
like that i liked it towards the end
yeah i like that like segment as well
but then uh it's like i don't want to
have to do it again also she probably
shouldn't be dying my hair when i
haven't got much left to it so
apparently that's a myth is it really
yeah it's not really yeah
my hairdresser was saying yesterday but
she got stakes in it it's her job to try
people's hair well no yeah but
that's true but also she was saying that
like unless you're like directly
applying the bleach onto the scalp which
yeah a hairdresser shouldn't be doing to
begin with it doesn't affect true i mean
i i don't know either way i'm i'm yeah i
know why you're cautious about i've got
out of that phase as well i feel like i
need to dye my hair i feel like i'm just
in the i'm in the boomer stage now where
i'm like it's it's you're at the you're
watching the veteran stage it'll it'll
do whatever it wants and i will just
deal with it
it does feel like regardless of age it
does feel like a stage that every
youtuber goes through yeah right it's
like oh it's the dyed it's it's either
they go through a bold stage or they dye
their hair
but it's it's the it's the i'm a
youtuber with a little bit of clout yeah
it's like oh
that is kind of like the youtuber
midlife crisis right oh people are
starting to look at me maybe i should
spice things up i never really wanted to
dye my hair it was like i think i was
what did you want to i think i was kind
of interested in it i was like i've
never tried it yeah i thought it could
be interesting and then when um uh char
who dyes your hair right yeah she was
just kind of like yeah let's just do it
and i was like i was like
i mean i think i was in that phase i was
like yeah [ __ ] it everything in my life
was changing why not yeah
so i tried it and i remember i didn't
like it initially i thought
okay
and then it got to blonde and i thought
huh weirdly looks okay yeah i didn't
mind blonde yeah but then also
it did make me look a bit weird i don't
think the silver looked weird on you to
be honest i think out of out of all the
i think that compared to like a red
or like a blue you know or like a you
know like a standard like i am a
youtuber youtube gamer color like yeah
yeah compared to that i think there's so
much
yeah uh ninja
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah ninja if you had
like me wrong if you had like if you had
ninja hair i would have been like
strong blue are you a twitch streamer
i mean i've done like what five or six
different colors now yeah i've done like
red blue green pink
purple and now i have this like gray
complete the rainbow yeah i have yeah
you just wake up day one day you're just
like i want to try something different
today starburst color am i doing today
yeah exactly but that's a that's a again
that's an easy way to date my videos
right like if like i know exactly what
era this video is from just based on
what kind of am i here yeah yeah so it's
kind of cool
but yeah i don't know it's like uh
like if you don't like this that's
totally fine uh you'll get used to it
within like a month you'll get used to
it with everyone yeah yeah i'm not even
used to it right now i woke up this
morning i was like that like who the
[ __ ] that i'm just praying i'm like
god please i hope i don't have a weird
shaped head when i get bald exactly that
was the one thing i was worried about
because
it really shapes out my face i don't
know how how do you how do you know what
your the shape of your head is you won't
know yeah you don't want to yeah until
you get to like this length and you're
like oh my head is [ __ ] weird i feel
like we should have found out a way to
figure out the shape of your head
without having to shave it all off
science come on we must have figured
something out right just like it scans
the contour of your head yeah i'm sure
there's like a [ __ ] filter or
something
yeah the filters always look so [ __ ]
it was like so cartoonishly bald
like like like
lex luthor wait no ball person
[Music]
um yeah aside from aside from joey
gang's haircut uh i
i watched another anime this uh this
this past weekend what did you watch i
watched jiu-jitsu tyson zero oh yeah in
in cinemas how was it it was
say it
say it god it was okay yeah
not midge
i liked it i thought it was good it was
good it was good it was it was
did you watch it in 4xd what's 4xd
whether like spit on you and shake the
chair and stuff
no i didn't know that was the top did i
have that for you yeah they did they
just
blow out
one person
i like the animation it was pretty uh i
don't know if watching demon slay has
just spoiled me in terms like shown in
animations but like
i went into like the the not with like
the expectations that it was going to be
demon slayer moog and train level uh but
i did come in knowing that that was the
last shown in anime film that i had
watched in theaters um and i came out
being just mildly amused and just
impressed by some animation points but
at the end of the day it was like the
most seven out of ten yeah i was going
to say it was the story good
was it okay
it was okay like okay
the people in the cinema next to me were
[ __ ] bowling their eyes oh yeah of
course i was like yeah you're good
literally everyone in the cinemas when i
watched mugen train was just like just
light sobbing from every corner of the
room and i'm just like okay oh now this
one next to me was like full on
balling and i was like
are you okay
yeah cause like to to me mugen train the
thing that made me train special for a
shonen anime film was that it actually
felt canon you know it actually felt
like it had a real tangible effect on
the story whereas i know that juju
sukaisen zero is technically canon
because it's technically supposed to be
a prequel but also it's like starring
like a main character that we hadn't
seen before
um and
it is canon it's pretty cool no it is it
is
it is it is canon but it didn't feel
like anything i watched in the movie had
any effect to like anything i watched in
the tv series
a little bit very minimal though like
mainly with the bad guy
mainly to do with the bad guy and then
i find i feel like i found out spoilers
from the people i was watching it with
and i was like oh okay so
i'm not i'm not going to tell you i'm
not gonna i'm not i'm not gonna spoil um
but it but it had like it didn't really
have that much of an effect it kind of
felt like a side story if anything
rather than actually having a proper
like i should care about all the things
going on and i think that's my problem
with a lot of shown in anime movies is
that there's
zero reason for me to care about
anything going on we spoke about this
like last time we said literally every
one-piece movie well yeah
you know it's a good experience but it
is a bit odd because it's like it's just
i think it's been number one at the box
office in japan for 10 weeks now yeah
yeah of course yeah it's just i'm not
just money printers yeah yeah
after mugen train this is like every
industry is just like eagle vision on
cinemas now it's just like that's that's
where the money is yeah i mean it feels
like the industry is definitely gearing
up more towards movies because like yeah
we were i mean the heavens feel was like
[ __ ] insane as well for that like
three month process of like all those
yeah because like because like when i
got invited to see jiu-jitsu
um i thought oh it's a bit late isn't it
it's is is it still gonna be in cinemas
uh because i missed out on seeing dune
because that was only in cinemas for
like a month and a half or maybe even
less in japanese cinemas but like
with anime movies it just seems like it
just never goes out dude mugen train was
in cinemas for a year yeah like what a
year like how how is it a year later
people are still seeing it in cinemas
and they're still making money of this
[ __ ] i mean that's i guess that's why
it's like the top grossing anime movie
of all time but like my time scale for
how long movies are in cinemas are like
completely [ __ ] destroyed by anime
movies because they just never seem to
they never seem to go out they never
seem to they always seem to be in there
how long has jesus christ hasn't been in
cinemas for now
oh
didn't it come out in it came out uh
christmas eve oh [ __ ] so it's almost
three months yeah almost three months
and it doesn't seem like it's even close
yeah too uh it doesn't seem like it's
either because they have showings in
four xd mxd or whatever yeah they have
uh 3d and they have all the atmos and
there's like in this a [ __ ] ton going
yeah
like when i was stuck in uh hokkaido
because the airport has a cinema there i
was like oh maybe i'll see what's
playing um literally every
literally it was jiu-jitsu zero for
every single place they didn't have any
other stuff no wait was it was it just
one screen was it multiple screens uh
i believe it was two screens oh yeah
okay that makes sense yeah because in
like in a there's a ton of cinemas all
around tokyo that have like 20 plus
screens or something ridiculous yeah and
you can watch there's tons of foreign
films so many of them and you can watch
jesus christ on seven of them
yeah i watched uh
operation mincemeat that's what it's
called the one with uh
colin first
that doesn't sound like a real movie
never heard of that at all it's about
like a world war ii operation where they
like made a
uh fake
person but they got a real dead body and
gave it fake documents and then washed
it up in spain was that like based off a
true story yeah it really happened oh
wow really cool really cool really
really cool story that's pretty good
basically like they wanted to make uh
germany think that the uk was going to
attack someone they weren't and so the
way they did it was by floating a body
to spain with fake documents on it and
then spain leaked it to germany and then
germany thought it was real stuff
because they made this person like look
so convincing that they were a real
person
it was a really cool story but the movie
was [ __ ]
oh okay is it is it a comedy it's a
drama but the problem i i guess oh there
wasn't [ __ ] it was a very
sick comedy five or six hours
no no it's like it's like
it's
focuses on like the personal drama
amongst the people who are doing the
operation yeah and so it's kind of like
it's like human drama i love triangle
and [ __ ] and it's like
what this is a [ __ ] war what's going
on what do we i mean i i i don't know i
always
the thing is so interesting itself the
whole story but obviously there's not
much known about it so they obviously
had to make it
right yeah and so it's kind of like
i mean colin firth's great he's always
great yeah but it was just kind of like
all right just me yeah well like like
going back to what you said about yeah
was [ __ ] like i was having this thought
the other day because like
i'm getting so bored of the word mid
right because like it just seems like i
like i tweeted out a tweet about like
[ __ ] demon slayer and the animation
and somehow that was like one of the
most toxic twitter tweets you tweeted
about demonstrate animation why would
you yeah yeah after what happened to me
why would i do that i just said demon
slayer had good animation and that that
that was it oh it was it was just like
oh yeah demon slayer i watch season two
and i'm like okay maybe it did deserve
best animation my [ __ ] god my like i
had i literally had to mute that thread
that thread compared to everything else
going on in the world that was the
threat that i had to mute in the past
i'm like gagging just thinking about
that comment people are clowns right
like it does have the best animation
it's not even like a contest but people
say there's other things about no it's
not is the story the best no but like
people are equating the fact that they
don't like the show or they don't like
how much attention it's getting yeah
being like it doesn't deserve the best
animation listen it does it like it just
flat out does yeah it does that mean
that it's it's a good show no no it
doesn't is it a mid shonen series like
story wise yes yes it is but it but but
the but
but the animation is [ __ ] dodgy
but it's the same reason why i watch
porn
i like i like what's going on on the
screen i don't like the plot i like that
i love demons
yeah but to sit here and be like it's a
complex storytelling no no
it's not it's a super simple shonen i i
think it's like
what does mid mean to you what does mid
mean to you what it means to me is that
you can watch it and there are many
aspects of it that you enjoy but there's
also a lot of aspects about it that just
don't grip you like there's a lot about
it like jesus
no to me no because because i was i was
having this thinking i think the the
story is made yeah yeah like you know
like as an overall show it's good i i
think the story is you know slightly
above me i think it's a solid story it
does everything slightly above
it was boring as [ __ ] i was bored out of
my mind watching that the whole way no
okay that was bits where it was good but
like the first first sixty percent the
first like seventy percent of that movie
yeah i was actually like resident
sleeper bro i was sleeping i i i agree
with you yeah
i think i think people forget that like
because everyone only thinks about the
last fight and like the last 30 minutes
of that movie because the last 30
minutes were [ __ ] great they were
[ __ ] amazing uh the actual part when
they were on the train was to me pretty
boring as [ __ ]
like going to the dreams i was just like
snooze yeah yeah yeah like literally
snooze literally snooze yeah i don't
know it's yeah yeah but like to me like
i had i had this realization that to me
like something [ __ ] like when i say oh
yeah it was pretty [ __ ] it was like it's
a five out of ten to me that's [ __ ]
right whereas you know like i don't know
why it's a five out of ten [ __ ] to you i
don't know why that's to me that board
is on like average yeah but when was the
last year you've got about ten things
you can tell yourself that five out of
ten in your head means that but it
doesn't five out of ten means right
because you're never going to give
anything a one unless you really hate it
right you're not you never hear
three or four see because in my head
like i'm operating on like the the my
anime list rating score right so when's
the last time you in your mind gave
something a 5 out of 10 you could be
watched read whatever right okay because
right because 7 out of 10 means that you
didn't hate it but you were happy like
you had an experience that you were
happy with yeah did it blow you away no
five out of ten means that you're not
sure if you wasted your time and that
that's why it feels weird giving things
you're like it's mid a five out of ten
because like i think a one out of ten
isn't even wasting your time because
that point at that point
at that point you watch a one out of ten
you're like this is just entertaining
this is this is so so bad this is so
like like you watch exam you watch
berserk 2016 you're like okay this is
obviously like [ __ ] terrible but i'm
having a good time watching this just to
[ __ ] on it but so that's like to me it's
like five is at the middle where it's
like all right if you do nothing
nothing good and nothing bad you get a
five right it's the most basic to me to
me a five out of ten when it comes to
anime to me a five out of ten is like i
finish watching it i feel nothing about
it and i forget about it in a couple
weeks 5 out of 10 for me is like have i
wasted my time i'm not sure yeah no no 5
out of 10 to me is have i wasted my time
yes this this was a waste of time it was
i i didn't but it wasn't
it's probably like the lowest that you
will ever finish a show because to me if
it's a three or four i probably watch
one or two episodes and i didn't even
finish it because there's nothing in
that to grab my attention five is just
like there was enough for me to finish
it and then i regret finishing it
because i just understand that yeah
because there was nothing in there that
made me want to like remember it or left
an impact on me but the five out of tens
are like in my opinion they're the worst
shows because you just they're just
thrown into this pile of like oh yeah
that existed would you give you juicy
tyson out of ten i give it like a seven
okay
because it's like because because no no
i wouldn't i wouldn't consider that it's
slightly it's okay
it's okay
see to me right when i hear it when you
say seven seven of me is like you were
happy and had fun watching it but the
moment it's over you don't feel
compelled by the show at all there's
nothing that makes it like really stick
in your memory it's like it's a good
experience and you don't regret it but
nothing after the fact makes you want to
actively think but that's that's the
thing it's like with judas kaisen like i
i finished it and it's like i had a you
know pretty good time watching it i was
like okay yeah this is this is good but
like when it was finished i was like am
i compelled to go read the manga or like
continue it on not exactly like to me my
hero academy is the exact same thing
where it's like season one it's like
yeah it was great yeah it was cool you
know i can see why people enjoyed it i
had a pretty good time with it am i
compelled to continue on with it
personally no what would you give the
did you watch the demonstration season
yet have you watched it yeah yeah what
would you give it i personally even
though i said the story is not the best
i still think it's like an eight or nine
i'd give it like a solid well it was hot
it was it went hard i would give it an
eight point five to nine um
and that's the the reason i say that
agreement the demon slayer councillors
yeah stronger strong
it was amazing because i don't agree
that the story is mid because a lot of
people say the story of demon slayer is
mid and to me like demon slayer's story
it
it's as simple as it needs to be right
yeah i i feel like it's as simple as it
needs to be to make the rest of the good
parts shine the problem with demon slay
is like when you have an arc like moog
and train and there are like fights that
aren't that don't stand out as much it's
like really
really apparent like just that the story
and the characters don't carry the show
as much but with
season two because the because half the
season was just a [ __ ] full-on action
fest you're like you're like [ __ ] out
this is like an eight or nine out of ten
i'm like that's that's that's the point
where okay i don't really care about the
story that much if the action just
[ __ ] slaps this hard yeah
you know what i mean how dare you say
the enemy you know what i mean how dare
you sit down
wow
i don't think we've ever talked about
that on the podcast
yeah yeah i'm too afraid
because i've been on the other side
quite recently can you cancel it about
talking about the animation
i'm just trying to think of like a five
out of ten this is the problem with
trying to
remember a five out of ten anime show is
that uh
i don't remember that's why they're a
five out of ten you know like
the moment
what about manga because you read more
manga because i can remember most five
ten shows it's literally like i go to
the list of isekai i finished i'm just
like a lot of these are literally five
out of ten even five out of ten manga
i'm like i don't
i just don't remember them and that's
the problem it's like it's so hard to
talk about
these kinds of like mediocre middle of
the ground shows it's because like
unless i recently re-watch it again i'm
not gonna remember it
i'm like oh yeah it's probably something
along those lines but i could wouldn't
be able to like you know concretely tell
you like this is the reason why it's a
five out of ten it's just so like
impactless that it's just like oh i
didn't even know that existed yeah you
know i do feel bad if you feel like
you've wasted a time watching a show no
um
[Music]
you don't
no i feel like when you start caring
that much about the
the media you're the media why sounds
like the media
you know the stuff you're consuming i
feel like
you almost ruined a lot of it for
yourself like stuff that you might have
enjoyed you just think you're worried
too much about if you're enjoying it the
whole time well that's kind of where i
got to unfortunately with that like it's
like i it got to the point where i was
so selective on what i was watching to
make sure that everything i was watching
was worth my time that if i ran into
something that i was like
well i just wasted an hour because of
watching these first three episodes
great i've i don't know if this is like
i haven't consciously chosen to do this
but i've stopped
scrolling or looking for shows
yeah it's just kind of whatever appears
in front whatever whatever is
recommended whatever is put in my head
or i think that's the best way to
consume media and honestly i've been
having a great time i i feel like i
honestly wish i honestly wish i could do
that
you have to watch anime well no it's not
even anime it's like pretty much every
form of media and it's not even about me
like being like a [ __ ] snob wanting
to like consume the best [ __ ] um it's
literally i started really caring about
it when i just didn't have the time
to do everything i wanted to do right so
like nowadays like even even if it's
just like picking a game i want it to be
a game i could probably get into like i
don't i don't know we are stuck in this
cycle of constantly worrying if the game
is good enough for your time and then
you know you'll never start yeah you
never [ __ ] play anything exactly yeah
yeah i mean that's what i feel games are
way more of a time sink than an anime
on average yeah i mean i mean it depends
well like to me getting into a game
getting like properly absorbed into a
game is just like it's one of the most
magical experiences and i [ __ ] love
it when i just get absorbed into a video
game world it's the same way that i get
absorbed into an anime or absorbed into
a manga or something like that
absolutely and like to me i don't know
like because my time is so precious to
me right now i'm
it sucks that i i like constantly have
to like have this little part of my head
that's just like oh could you be
watching something better that you'd
enjoy maybe a little bit more no are you
really in the mood for this yeah
optimize your schedule in every way
right yeah so i feel like the stuff that
you consume should be the one thing
where you're like no pressure like
whatever you watch whatever you play
doesn't matter if it wasn't the game of
the year it doesn't matter if it wasn't
the movie of the year yeah just watch
whatever comes up so i have an opinion
on it like i watch that uh don't look up
oh yeah yeah what a [ __ ] movie uh what
an awful movie that was a five-hour term
i hated that
you hated that i hated it
a lot of people hated it [ __ ] bought
and it went on for like an
hour longer than it needed to right
right and like yeah there were some
funny moments of it there were some bits
that i chuckled but overall i just felt
like i i wasted my time yeah but
i was like i'm glad i watched this
because it gave me even though i i came
out
disliking the movie for some reason that
made me happy i was like yeah that was
[ __ ] and it was fun getting to talk to
other people who also thought it was
[ __ ] i don't know i just liked it i
think as well it's because like even
even if you do consume something that is
[ __ ] within that like specific medium
like it just broadens your horizon more
on the medium and like it adds to the
knowledge pool of like oh now that i've
consumed something on the other side of
the spectrum now i'm i'm a little bit
more knowledgeable about what makes the
good [ __ ] good right yeah i'm definitely
like that with music where i'm like if
it's on [ __ ] spotify i'm just
listening to it right like i i watched
um as well i watched uh
uh spiderman movie the new one oh yeah
yeah and like yeah it was great but i
because it was great and i had a good
time
my emotions are way stronger about don't
look up right really i hated it right
yeah you had more to talk about yeah i
have more i watched i watched no way
home and i had a great time but at the
end of the day i've already like
forgotten about it and i don't care and
it was yeah it was good but it was just
that was a movie i [ __ ] loved i was i
liked it a lot but i just i'm after i'm
done with it i'm like that was
everything i expected it to be right and
i had fun but i don't feel strongly
about it i think that's the thing though
it's like the the problem is like i
think the sweet spot of like
you being able to like really gush out
about something is like when it's on two
or the two ends of the spectrum right
where it's either like so [ __ ]
incredible like 10 out of 10 masterpiece
where you can just gush about your love
for it forever and then there's the
other side where it's like let me tell
you about how absolutely atrocious this
[ __ ] yeah dude i watched um uh could you
google this for me actually it's uh
robert patterson's movie uh i forgot the
name [ __ ] i watched it like three weeks
ago
no no no no it's been a five out of ten
yeah yeah right right it must have been
a fight it's amazing oh yeah
yeah dude good time please [ __ ] watch
a good time it's so good this movie was
amazing
i want you to watch it so badly so we
can talk about it because it's what's it
about i don't want to say anything but
go into it have you watched uncut gems
yeah you know like how it's just anxiety
simulator yeah it's it's that and and
like right it is literally like anxiety
simulation okay it's so good it's
amazing and it's just like a movie that
when you watch it i just felt like
this was just i'm so glad i watched this
movie i just felt like i had like
experienced something special that a lot
of love and care went into and that
everyone really just brought their a
game like it was just amazing please
watch it it's so good a lot of
resistance
no no years ago oh okay came out 2017.
yeah yeah so again go and watch it it's
really good um i absolutely adore all of
his stuff i think he's really good in a
lot of things i'm really hyped for him
as batman i'm high from
yeah every movie i've watched with him
after twilight he chose weird ass roles
that were just so good and he just
nailed it but that's that's what i love
about like that's what i love about
actors like that though because daniel
radcliffe did the exact same thing right
it's like usually those like super
popular type casted characters who are
like
now people are just going to know me as
this [ __ ] forever so i'm just going to
go into all the like all the way
like all the weird artsy like daniel
radcliffe movies like i've seen so many
of them and they're just like
man like [ __ ] respects dude like you
can do [ __ ] later now he's like doing
broadway [ __ ] yeah he's doing that right
afterwards it's [ __ ] great like he's
like yeah good on you i feel like that
like actors going weird and doing weird
films is like the actual equivalent of
the youtuber game the hair dye
it's like guys i want an image change
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna do a bunch
of weird [ __ ] now right
sure because they've all gone on like
shia labeouf as well
all the weird [ __ ] afterwards as well
which one do you do uh nymph
informaniac [ __ ] that was a weird watch
yeah watch that go on no i want god to
watch this
it's uh what's the [ __ ] uh director's
name he's it's like the really
informatic is right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's about information
it's you know that's a three-parter yeah
yeah it's a three-part it's a trilogy no
it's
like of that universe oh no the one with
the shadow buff movies are two yeah it's
a universe
there's like a tree it's like a trilogy
of las vegas and nympha maniac i think
is the third one
you should something like that it is
it is a [ __ ] weird movie it's amazing
uncomfortable and it yeah it's like las
vegas like known to face some really
disturbing movies yeah an infamous
probably i've seen all the lives of
entrepreneur movies and nymphomaniacs
easily the [ __ ] weirdest one and i
was like oh charlotte buffs it's like
you just go what the [ __ ] you just go
from even stevens like shut up sis and
it's like oh gosh oh god oh goodness
i didn't i didn't i didn't wish to see
charlotte buff's butthole in different
scenes but there it is i guess i didn't
mean to watch this movie it came on the
tv how did you see it it was on tv i was
i was on tv uh i was in a hotel and like
isn't it like an x-rated movie i think
it's in like bulgaria and it was on tv
or something
you watched it
i i know i watched it i watched it in a
european country and it was on tv at
like 2am and i couldn't sleep and i
remember i just i remember just thinking
like what the [ __ ] i felt like a [ __ ]
fever dream yeah it was weird that yeah
anything lost one train makes is a
[ __ ] fever tree it's weird man how do
you f how do you guys think like trash
tv fits into everything would you call
trash t like which what rating would you
give like kitchen nightmares or
something like that or uh 90 day fiance
i think it just depends because like
people it depends if you grew up on it
or not
right like during like you know were you
were you surrounded of gordon ramsay
yeah yeah yeah i'm in i'm invested in
that character i like it i know that
most of it especially in kitchen
nightmares like all faked [ __ ] but also
that's the thing
it depends on like if you were like
raised in a family where like it was
like a family event to be like oh it's
wednesday night let's watch kitchen
nightmares you know that kind of thing
right like i didn't grow up in a family
like that so like to me like i didn't
grow up with trash tv at all so yeah we
never watched it together yeah so when i
was like youtube yeah oh okay okay so
like cause like the first time i knew
about like kitchen nightmare was like
through like youtube clips
or like any tlc show right i was like
what the [ __ ] is this yeah yeah just
because like i knew kitchen nightmares
uh because that was like literally when
i first saw gordon ramsay as well it was
it was the british kitchen nightmares as
well which was like you compare british
kitchen nightmares to american kitchen
nightmares and it's like [ __ ] night
and day
like not only the editing but just how
like toned down gordon ramsay is as well
down in the british one yeah he's he's
toned down
he's like he it it's it's different
right because it feels like in the
american one it feels like they actually
get like a formula huh it is a formula
but you know
it feels like they get like the worst of
the worst [ __ ] chefs and restaurant
like actual clowns yeah uh to to like
present their dish to gordon ramsay and
it's almost like cartoonish in a way and
yeah you look at the british one and it
feels like
it's just like like chefs who actually
give a [ __ ] about their food who
actually just like you just need some
advice who needs some advice a lot of
the times gordon ramsay is like giving
them like genuine advice and maybe
they're too headstrong or maybe they're
too like you know prideful to really
listen to his advice whereas you know in
america it actually feels more like this
is
this is not even reality tv anymore this
looks so cartoony it feels so over the
top that you just don't even take it i
feel that way about like 99 of american
trash tv no you know which one the one i
hate the most i i hate it because i i
used to also watch it a lot the [ __ ]
porn stars oh yeah what's that one you
you know it it's the one you know it's
it's the it's the one it's set in vegas
right it's like the one with the bald
guy and someone comes in he's like i've
got a i've got this thing worth 20
million dollars and he's like i'll give
you 10 bucks for it yeah oh oh i thought
he said porn stars like like pawn we're
british
at the same way pawn stars
no i thought he was a [ __ ] show about
little porn stars i was like what is
this reality tv show
stars and there's also hardcore porn
as well which is the other one there was
like a spin-off to that there was like a
british version of it as well which was
just like what was it called
porn in it
car boot sailors or something like that
right yeah so like it was like that show
is just because it's so forgot it's so
obviously fake but also at the same time
you're like
it's just cool just seeing weird [ __ ]
brought in i've i've driven past uh the
porn stars players
they don't even film it in there no they
don't know
that they just they just
and it's just like because it's in the
most ghetto part of vegas it's so scary
and then like you know there'll be this
this guy comes in he'll be like i have
this uh mummified corpse that's been
sitting in my grandma's attic in nevada
yeah right he's like oh you know i know
an expert i'm gonna bring him down and
ten seconds later the expert's there
he's like well it is a mummified corpse
uh it's worth about fifty thousand
dollars and then he goes i'll give you
20 bucks for it what am i gonna do with
the mum five cooks we're gonna do with
that it's just so dumb
the whole formula [ __ ] and then they
just walk out angrily it's like you're
missing out on a great deal man
yeah i mean what i did what i didn't
understand about porn stars it's like
when they started starting i guess
introducing story lines like like or
play classic
yeah they would be like b-line plus with
their family that would get resolved in
an episode like it's a episode of like
happy days or something like that with
storage wars as well yeah oh my god i
remember the story that was so big in
the uk the american one played in the on
uk television so [ __ ] great yeah it
was so popular it was ridiculous yeah i
just i just like yeah thinking back on i
used to yeah that was the one actually
trash tv i came on australian tv all the
time and my dad was obsessed i just
loved it because they were just they
would literally be a pile of [ __ ] in
this room and these guys are like so
about 50 bucks sell it for 20 bucks like
where are you going to sell this to
there's like a used bed she's like
that's five bucks right there it's like
no it's not you're not selling whatever
what if so it's like all connected like
like the trash tv universe where like
they think tv like like in storage wars
they like they take all the [ __ ] and
then they go to the porn stars
because it's like half the time you know
of course there'll be these ones these
fake ones will be like this guy has a a
lot full of perfect rarity charizards
perfect grain it's like well obviously
we can sell those but other times
there's just lots or something where
it's just all [ __ ] and you're like even
if you could make a profit selling this
surely the amount of time to get rid of
all of this [ __ ] and sell it it's just
not worth it no like yeah you could sell
this the pack of double a batteries for
10 bucks if you really wanted to but why
would you like where are you going to
sell this to like are you shipping it
surely that has to be taken into account
this is this is the only country where i
see that working you know where you
where you can actually sell this stuff
and people will buy it they do have
storage lots in japan but i don't think
they sell them do they when they
when they no i don't i'm pretty sure
they actually use storage for storage
purposes but the store is a lot i think
when if somebody doesn't collect it i
think they just get rid of all the stuff
yeah they just don't think they sell
them to the public which would be shame
because we did japan storage wars
version
that would be all these walls dude that
would be epic tonight directly you can
get a great deal
like what kind of what like i think i
know more american reality tv shows and
i know british reality tv shows i can't
think of like we have uh we have a naked
attraction you know i'm naked attraction
i love that when i went back to the uk i
really like that was on that was still
on tv it was still airing on child about
sure you know the ones that actually the
one i the one there's a real tv show
where you feel bad watching but even if
it's i don't know how much of its fake
like you know the debt collectors won oh
yeah that's the one where i'm always
like even if this is fake should we
really be which one's storylines it's
like uh there's a bunch in the uk we
[ __ ] love debt collecting shows in
the uk for some
reason we love watching debt collectors
as long as we're not on the budget yeah
so what's the premise
just go and collect debts it's just like
it's just like jim is is
the bank fifty thousand dollars and so
jeremy over here is going to go over to
his house and collect this let's see
what happens but in the in the british
one it's just like some guy goes to
their house hey we've come here to get
the stuff and then like [ __ ] off man no
you're [ __ ] getting my thing [ __ ]
right off and they're like they've got a
high high magistrates caught notice to
collect the stuff if they don't they'll
start collecting things off the property
and then they and then the police turn
up and then it's just it's just [ __ ]
because it's like oh these poor people
who've had a horrible circumstance and
then we're just we're just shoving
cameras in their face while their
apartment's being ransacked and so yeah
and the sun
it's
i guarantee if you watch one you'll get
hooked it's it's horrible tv
it's just the trash
channel
like it's so addictive watching this
stuff like to me like i don't know why
you just can't help yourself to me like
channel 4 is where a lot of like the
trash tv goes yeah um even though i
can't like think of any channel 4 is
good stuff too though yeah but channel 4
is i think china was like actually one
of like the best the best channel was it
has like the widest range it seems like
to be the most experimental as well bbc
is just like very standard here's your
like [ __ ] doctor who's the voice
here's the voice itv is just like here's
his x factor once again that's a reality
tv show actually yeah that's right yeah
i completely forgot that's just like
reality tv show just like times 100
though right but no no one cares about
singing reality like does it is still
going huh does anyone is next factor
still happening oh yeah i'm sure i'm
pretty sure does anyone give a [ __ ] love
island as well love island that's is
that is that itv i feel like that's itv
yeah so you've got like i feel like
that's really popular in america as well
the british one yeah it's really popular
yeah it is oh the great british break
off as well i completely forgot about it
you can't be called bake off in the u.s
really they can't uh one of the the us
brands has um
the trademark
uh one of them has the the trademark to
be take off so they it's called
something else in america and they've
had to like
something and they've had to actually in
the netflix i think on netflix they've
had to like
animate over certain parts of the show
like the trophy they've had to like they
they
did a they did see cgi where they trade
that changed what the trophy said wow oh
it's called the great american baking
show yeah the great american baking show
yeah because they didn't have the rights
for the wood bake off oh wow cause for
some reason a company owns the right for
the word bake off which is weird um so
yeah they changed it so that that is
popular in the us but it's called
technically something different the
baking show
the great british breaking shirt just
just doesn't roll off the tongues words
i know right i know does australia have
any reality tv shows uh i mean we got
like australian idol and like the voice
australia and like all that [ __ ] um how
did the voice get popular i like i like
at which point in time did we decide we
need more than one singing reality tv
show when was x factor just not enough i
think it's because like shows like x
factor and like american idol were like
uh a lot of the times there was like
contestion of like are they like judging
them on their actual singing or are they
judging them on their performance so
people are like we want to know if they
can actually sing and looks don't matter
you know like that whole like [ __ ]
like you know
like inclusive things yeah how they
treat you the audience is idiots and
feed you these garbage story lines yeah
i also just get confused about like the
judges on a lot of people like x factor
has like or brilliant has like [ __ ]
ruined so many [ __ ] songs for me just
because of like they use it at like the
emotional the emotional point like if i
hear like you raise me up one more
[ __ ] time it's always you raise me up
right yeah like golden boss
it's like the x factor
they didn't didn't win susan boyle right
yeah yeah doesn't win no she came second
right
did susan boyle win
so it's like that that is like the peak
of how tv manipulates yeah yeah the us
to just wanna you know they'll give you
an underdog and they've got a sad story
oh no i've never had a boyfriend oh oh
no you know and and the show doesn't
give a [ __ ] they ever had a boyfriend
but they're like look audience care care
about this care about this they do all
the time uh as well with like military
stuff yeah yeah they're like you know
they'll
you know there'll be someone who wants
to compete who maybe like served in uh
afghanistan or something and instead of
just being like hey this is the town
it's like no you're the guy who went to
afghanistan your whole identity is about
going to afghanistan and you and you're
doing this for your troops back in
afghanistan because they're one last
wishes to see you perform that's what
they do that's what they do yeah i was
watching a thing with um chris in the
hotel room
and it was a british got britain's got
talent person who um was performing
magic and they served in the military
yeah yeah yeah and it was just insulting
how they almost just shoved it down your
throat it's like this is the guy's only
re reality as a human being
is that he served in a war and it's like
can we not just be people do we have to
just like have do we do we do we have to
just shove down these things
how about you follow the name of your
show and just be like do you have a
talent yes or no this is not about this
but how is your story compelling yeah so
on this magic show this guy is doing
these tricks and stuff and you know not
to to not to minimize it but it was
almost beat for be predictable and
there's just
this so this is one trick where he was
doing and he was like oh look at the the
clock and and tell me the time and so
right before the the point of this trick
goes i was like chris to chris i was
like because chris is watching it yeah
and i was like
i bet it's the time where one of his
friends died or something in the war
yeah no a [ __ ] you not two seconds later
he's like that's the time when my friend
passed oh my god and it's like okay
don't get me wrong i want to say that
like that is obviously horrific and
stuff but yeah the fact that they're
using this as like bait almost like even
trivial trivialized because if it
doesn't feel real it does like the
impact is gone because it feels so
manufactured it's just it's just like
they might as well have just put up a
cue card to be like now cry yeah yeah
yeah
again i want to make sure i'm not
diminishing it or like you know trying
to minimize minimize it or make it seem
like it's not on the guy it's on the
editor
it's on the producers yeah the shows
probably heard this story or something
they're like yo play that up play that
people want to [ __ ] cry yeah because
like because like it's been proven
plenty of times that the
the auditions that we see televise in
front of a live audience isn't actually
like the first audition they go through
like several stages with the producers i
guarantee he was doing that magic trick
and like one of the producers like just
like
heavily suggested yo you should you
should we don't know speculation by the
way speculation speculation but uh i
like in my mind i'm just like
i feel like one of one of the producers
just went you know we i feel like you
should uh
kind of like try to integrate that
storyline into your magic trick somehow
you know it's definitely kind of stuff
that those you know producers are
would do like we've seen you know if you
have a look at the people have released
the contracts and stuff they're pretty
predatory contracts oh yeah yeah yeah i
think a lot of the time i think i
covered which one it was either one of
these shows one of the british ones is
like
they by signing the contract
they owned everything that you would
make that you would self-publish online
or something i think it was american
idol one of them was like yesterday yeah
if you went to even audition and you
posted content online if they wanted to
they could turn around and be like hey
that's us we that's us bro yeah that's
just [ __ ]
because i think everyone at the time i
remember when this was happening when i
was younger and everyone was like oh
susan ball is going to win so like yeah
it was a big effort to like make it so
that she didn't win or like right
opinion this is when people gave a [ __ ]
about reality tv yeah
now life is the reality tv we don't need
this [ __ ] we are like just log on to our
[ __ ] twitter and uh you you get to
see reality tv where's where's susan
boyle now hopefully doing well for
herself but no one's talking about her i
i i would like to go on the go back to
the times when we could just [ __ ] on
reality tv and that that just have like
zero effect in our lives yeah that's
that's the good old days for me this
episode is sponsored by manscaped splish
splash i was taking a bath and i noticed
i have beautiful balls you do connor you
do our friends at manscape tm the global
leader in below the waist hygiene are
turning men's shower dreams into their
favorite routine with the all-new ultra
premium collection
this all-in-one hygiene skin and hair
bundle is designed to upgrade the
everyday men's shower routine from head
to toe your skin hair and balls deserve
this save big by going to manscape.com
for 20 off plus free shipping with the
code trash taste so manscape recently
just released a deodorant and i got to
say guys this is what a sigma male 7
oh you know as well gentlemen that uh
manscaped has started doing lip balms as
well which is good because especially
during like the winter time in japan the
air is very very dry and i get chapped
lips like crazy so get twenty percent
off plus free shipping with the code
trash taste at manscape.com that's 20
off plus free shipping without code
trashtaste.manscape.com it's time to get
wet and clean with your new manscaped
shower routine this bundle will change
your life
have you ever thought about
going on a show like that at all that's
a great question
yeah no a part of me is like
okay i saw a guy on youtube uh i think i
showed you guys he went on the show
playing a character and then like just
making fun of the whole process and like
with secret camera and stuff showing you
oh really yeah but then i think the show
took everything down oh yeah but it was
because you signed the contract yeah you
had to sign the contract yeah but
eponymous thought i wonder if i made up
a storyline and i really committed to it
how easy would it be to get on tv yeah i
think it would be pretty easy which
comedian did this a british one did it
didn't he did he
i wouldn't i wouldn't put it past
british communities which one was it
[ __ ] he made up like a storyline about
i think it was um
oh which comedian was it was it
ah british comedian who went on
britain's got talent and it was there
was like i don't want to say the
storyline in case i'm wrong
oh let me google let me do a bit more
not sure give us a second
british comedian he did like he made it
so that like his i think his backstory
is a holocaust survivor or something
really yeah yeah something like that or
something like jewish or something i
remember it was like that while he's
searching i'll guess i'll get out onto
the conversation yeah like i don't know
why people would want to go on reality
tv shows now when you can just post
yourself up on youtube i feel like that
need to like have your five seconds of
fame is kind of like
that need is like kind of disappearing
because at any moment in time you post a
tick tock you can get like a few million
views i like had a complete chance right
well reality tv has figured this out
that's why they often recruit people on
social media yeah they go on social
media and like dm them like hey we're
from this britain's got town would you
be interesting auditioning we can
guarantee you together to like the
second judges or something sneaky
[ __ ] well yeah have you not
watched like clips of the talent shows
recently i haven't actually it feels
less like a talent show and more like
hey
because there's people who are like from
all over the world like american and
canadian it just seems like they're just
getting anyone who does anything
interesting right to come on and who has
a compelling story supposedly yeah it's
more like that less so a talent show of
the people and more a talent show to
just amuse to people where they just get
active across the world yeah yeah and
then just loosely tie together a story
it's the real youtube rewind now since
youtube rewind isn't the thing anymore
the talented people rewind yeah i'll
have to find it after okay but what was
the story then was so he made up that he
was a holocaust victim can i have your
phone i can try and google it i can't
remember oh here we go yeah lee nelson
yeah he's by channel four
what is this one
thumbnail
oh my god wow and i think he made up a
fake storyline about being a rabbi and
something and then whatnot and channel
four posted it was part of like balls of
steel like balls of steel yeah oh i
remember balls of steel i didn't know i
didn't even know that was still going on
geez it's not this is from a while back
oh okay i remember he made up some story
about being a hebrew um rabbi and
playing a bunch of generic sympathy
cards yeah and yeah and it was really
easy for him to get on yeah and then i
think he got to the live show i can't
remember what happened exactly i think
he then came out or something yeah it
was yeah but it was just like showing
how easy it is to fake
stuff yeah i mean like i like because i
haven't watched much reality tv show not
like much like of these talent shows i
should say uh as much as i used to
because before like it felt like
everyone was talking about it especially
when you live it was like inescapable
yeah everyone was talking about oh he's
going to win bruins or talon or x-factor
now it just feels like i don't i don't
know if it's if it's just my social
circle has changed or if the viewership
has genuinely just had a sharp drop-off
but like i rarely hear anyone talking
about these big talent shows anymore no
one cares because no one really like the
the demographic of watching tv now is
just completely shifting yeah i feel tv
is just background noise now yeah that's
it no one actually gives a [ __ ] about
what's going on tv yeah like i feel
you know well at least people under 40.
yeah like i feel like
people nowadays would rather oh well
obviously would rather get on a [ __ ]
mr beast video or something
yeah definitely you know it is weird
actually i had this thought the other
day where that's that's the new like
america's got talent like
yeah i did have this thought the other
day and correct me if i've already
talked about this on the podcast because
i can't remember if i have or not uh but
it feels like youtube in a sense has
like because the internet moves so fast
youtube has become the new tv and it's
almost like tick tock that's become the
new youtube in a sense where tick tock
is this like
big like this big rising piece of you
know piece of media and like remember
back in the day where every youtuber
like you you know you have made it as a
youtuber if you could appear on tv if
you could appear on old media nowadays
it feels like every tick tocker is
trying to make a name for themselves on
youtube and it's like youtube that is
the established media and the
established platform yeah
i definitely think so yeah just like
another transition of
yeah just we i don't know but like at
the same time as well it's like almost
there's a lot of youtubers now doing the
opposite where they're like they're
trying to jump onto tick-tock now and
making a name for themselves there
because they think you know it's the
whole
grass is greener on the other side
concept right where it's like which is
the real
mean source of like
how many youtubers do you know because i
don't know
many aside from i think hank green's the
only one i've seen a lot on like tick
tock and like youtube shorts but he's
really fun to watch
is moving away from tick tock to like
he's going to like instagram
instagram or whatever the thing now
isn't it i've seen [ __ ] ray william
johnson on tick tock oh my god seeing
ray william johnson just like dude
yeah seeing ray william johnson do
equals three content on tick tock is
like insane it's so weird because it is
literally just like equals three content
yeah right it's just like this is the
[ __ ] he was making 15 years ago on
youtube yeah yeah he's weird and like oh
and like all these like eugene kids are
just like hey have you heard of this
like hilariously new wacky guy caller
well i mean it's it's making numbers
yeah surprise things make numbers on
tick tock [ __ ] oh yeah of course but
here's your [ __ ] but i mean yeah
are you saying it's just okay
it's mid
is it is it actual middle you know is it
like five out of ten
that's right it was mid content on tick
tock william johnson
but hey if you like to support the show
then go over to our patreon patreon.com
trashcase also follow us on twitter send
us a means on the subreddit and if you
hate our face listen to us on spotify
it's a next week where we [ __ ] and fart
everywhere
bye
[Music]
foreign